so we ended up that night like going out
somewhere after that even I I think it
was that night yeah I I I don't I don't
that whole part of my life was kind of a
blur okay kind of a blur I don't I don't
really remember I used to come home at
like 78 in the morning like every night
um that's when you know when you move to
Vegas and you have a little bit of
success you're just like you're out
every night and
um you you run we we didn't plan it we
just ran into each other I think Tom
Green came I think it was me and Tom
Green maybe katop but then we just like
flave is everywhere now like you just
run into him and he's one of my he's
been to my show like 50 times yeah I
love him too I love all these guys man
he lives out in Vegas now right yeah
yeah he's he's been in Vegas for some
time and he's been my brother he he
comes to my house on Fourth of July and
he brings like $10,000 worth of
fireworks and I live in like a in an
area that like has like four houses in a
gated community and he like it looks
like a third world country when he's
done there is like paper and fires and
I'm like worried like we're going to get
like you know get arrested um something
that you have no experience in right but
uh but yeah these these were the times
you know like this was exciting you know
this was craziness and um you know now I
have three kids I chill and since then
huh so yeah I've been busy wow I'm old
I'm 56 dude I have three I have a
2-year-old man that's crazy so we hung
out that night for the first time and
and and we and we settled something I
didn't even remember that I'd said
anything at a public level but I I had
effectively attacked you there was a me
yeah how did you attack me it was and
you physically no no no I remember you
you called me out about it too what it
was was you had a a huge rad stunt that
you did where like you were suspended
with hooks going through your back I
remember that well and somebody asked me
about it or something and I was like ah
like it like the hooks through the back
I I don't think it's really funny or
something oh definitely wasn't
it was [__] painful yeah I like I
would have I I was like I maybe I would
have done uh I would have done it with
hooks through my butt cheeks or
something I don't know well you're
crazier than me yeah you know I'm I'm
I'm in the world of Illusion even though
I Had No Illusion I had no painkillers
no numbers and I I I hung for 6 hours I
broke the record yeah you're you're not
trying to get the humor out of it I was
ever the first person I ever hang from a
helicopter I didn't realize that the
helicopter with the camera was going to
create turbulence and it was
excruciatingly painful I was up there
for 30 something minutes but no I didn't
do it as like a jackass thing right
right right you know I did it as like
you know Mind Over Matter kind of thing
to try to inspire people that you know
are trying to accomplish things that
look impossible trying to show you that
anything is possible yeah and and dude
I'm I'm I'm thrilled that you don't even
remember that no good steo who no I'm
just
kid how long does it take to prep for
something like that the helicopter one
um well I produced the show and uh and
so it was when I first went up I felt
like I was going to puke so they had to
bring me down and the guy that does the
Pearson Alan Faulkner I think his name
was nice guy said once you come down
you're never going to go back up and I I
I was like the money is on the line with
me because if I don't do it I lose all
this money that I now have to create
content that I've already spent for
helicopters this location so I had to
ruce it didn't matter what I thought and
it was very difficult to get back up but
I uh I did and I was up there for like
35 minutes flying around with four Fish
Hooks through my back the first person
to ever do this and then prior to this I
hung for 6 hours in Time Square and you
know you've seen all things in Time
Square but when you see a dude hanging
for 6 hours in the middle of Broadway
and 43rd people like like looking at me
in like in a puke because the skin the
stretches but yeah steo if you would
have if you would have done this you
would have done it like I mean you know
in some crazy I I don't know if you
could physically do that you'd rip your
ball balls right off because because if
you if if the hook goes into shallow it
rips out of your skin if it goes in too
deep it could do muscle damage so it's
really it's really dangerous at that
point in my life I was doing [__] I
spent 24 hours on the water I did a lot
of [__] that like I would never do today
you know kids and everything but I was
so desperate to to achieve what I had in
my head that I didn't give a [__] what
the consequences were like I said either
I'm going to get out of this condition
physically you know on my own terms or
you're going to pull me out in the body
bag there was no like there was no way I
was going to lose I was going to die
trying that's how bad I wanted to
succeed in my life I I just I just was
willing to die from my art
why were you ready to throw up on there
because of the pain or because of the it
was it you know when your skin separates
from your muscle and you're hanging
basically like you know when you pick up
a cat by the neck that's kind of how
you're hanging you're hanging from your
skin all of the weight of everything
internally is just like
stretched and uh it it's just insanely
painful I only had one other thing that
was more painful than that and that was
believe it or not I I shot something and
I had to put Prosthetics on my face and
when the guy removed the Prosthetics
either the the the liquid that he was
using to remove the glue or something
got into my air eard drum and I wanted
to take a gun and blow my brains out the
pain was I couldn't it just was just
nonstop pain it was the craziest pain I
ever had worse than anything I ever
experienced and that was second but you
you have done things and I'm going to
ask you this when we do my podcast but
the things that you have done you know
without really a lot of planning like
you've done a lot of things like just
I'm going to do this and just had
something to drink and Bam literally did
the craziest things that literally could
have killed yourself and you've ended up
in a hospital so many times like what
was the mental state
to do that and how did you prepare or
you didn't prepare like I just said just
did it
um yeah the uh the the the mental state
I think that my my general position is
that my need for attention outweighs my
need for safety and comfort so you are
willing to die for your for your for
your performance art yeah pretty much we
have that in common I mean that's the
the hard part is like cuz because
there's no planning with Steve it's all
like spontaneous or as close as you can
get so me having the plan like help call
the places and get it approved like I
think I think it'd be a lot easier if we
had like a three days to prep but like
sometimes we have like four hours yeah
you you you have to I did like over a
thousand demonstrations just on mind
freak and I had to do 28 episodes in one
season so that would be you know 10 to
demonstrations that I had to have
prepared and the sheer volume of doing
that you just don't have that time and
you don't have that budget so it it's
like you know you just you you take
chances I took a shitload of chances I I
was on Planet Hollywood 30 mph winds
trying to walk down it 550 ft in the air
with no safety like it was the craziest
thing like I have video of this and my
brother freaking out because he thinks
I'm going to get blown over then the
cops come because I wasn't known at that
time and people thought like I was a
jumper but so how long are you how long
does it take you to prep for something
like that well then no time if I'm doing
something now I have a team you know I
these Studios these are my buildings so
I we fabricate everything we do
everything engineering you know we we we
do everything in house so it becomes um
it's a very different Dynamic than when
you're doing it in your garage you know
and you have two people doing it with
you do you like shopping on Amazon I do
and good news is sto's butt wipes for
your butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get sto's hot sauce for your
butthole plus sto's butthole destroyer
and steo butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right
now yeah dude